this video was supported in part by our
friends at curiosity stream what if
viewers get 30 days completely free when
they click on the link in the
description below and use the promo code
what if after twenty two hundred and
fifty medical trials involving three
hundred and eighty thousand patient
volunteers your wishes and your prayers
have finally been answered we found a
cure for cancer what if that were true
how would it work how many lives would
we save and would there be any side
effects this is what if and here's what
would happen if we found a cure for
cancer your body heals itself but that's
not our answer that's our problem the
trillions of cells that make up your
body are constantly copying and dividing
themselves to become new cells that will
replace the old and worn-out ones but
when an old cell refuses to step aside
that's what we call cancer it can take
many forms but at the center of it all
is a bad cell that doesn't go away when
it's supposed to and then it divides and
conquers in 1971 US President Richard
Nixon declared war on cancer today were
on the brink of bringing it to an end
more than 250 years of cancer research
so far has led to significant advances
in cancer patients quality of life and
life expectancy we've reached a point
where some of the most commonly
diagnosed cancers have a survival rate
of over 90% after five years nonetheless
cancer remains the second leading cause
of death around the world it's time for
a cure in 2019 an Israeli biotech
company declared that it had a cure
which it described as a cancer
antibiotic the company developed a
molecular toxin that could connect to a
series of cancer cells and destroy them
all in just one treatment
of course this claim raised many
eyebrows first of all because it's hard
to differentiate good cells from bad
ones there's a risk of hitting the wrong
target but more importantly this cure
hasn't been tested on humans luckily
that's only one potential cure among
several ideas that are being tested
another treatment might include
self-regulating nanoparticles that are
designed to kill cancer cells meanwhile
scientists are also working on ways to
stop nutrients from feeding and growing
a malignant tumor whichever method might
actually be able to cure cancer it still
doesn't mean we'll eradicate it after
all it's just a cure it's not a vaccine
which means new cases of cancer will
still occur knowing there's a cure
some people might decide to live more
dangerously they might not be as
inclined to quit smoking or to eat
healthier unless they couldn't afford to
continue their bad habits the US has the
best cancer survival rates in the world
thanks to sophisticated medication and
technology but all that comes at very
high prices often costing hundreds of
thousands of dollars if a company did
develop a successful cancer cure we can
almost guarantee that it wouldn't be
cheap the economic impacts of this
discovery would affect pharmaceutical
companies around the world as well as
people in about 70 different medical
professions people in developing
countries might not even have access to
the cancer cure meaning that their lives
would barely be affected by this
breakthrough at least not immediately
while a cure for cancer might begin as
costly and exclusive it would still be
among the biggest milestones in medical
history and we could probably employ the
same research techniques or technology
to fight other challenging diseases so
if you're a doctor or a scientist who is
watching this right now get back to
working on that cure but when it's time
for a break or a little inspiration
we'll be waiting for you right here with
another what-if
thanks again to our friends at curiosity
stream for lending their support to this
video
curiosity stream is the subscription
streaming service with thousands of
award-winning documentaries and
nonfiction titles for you to choose from
you can get unlimited access to
curiosity stream starting at just $2.99
a month or just $19.99 a year and what
if viewers get the first 30 days
completely free all you have to do is
sign up at curiosity stream comm slash
what if and use the promo code what if
during the signup process